so um but we we have carries joining us
to start and uh
carrie is a liberal i am still a liberal
you're still but i voted for trump so
i'm a bit of a reluctant deplorable as
what i like to call it but you chose to
be a deplorable i did
after a long consideration four years
and actually cassandra
is one of the people i was watching with
curiosity because
i voted for biden in 2016 and you were
someone i was watching because i thought
okay she was also for not for biden
sorry for bernie
she was also for bernie and then she
went over to trump and it was really
confusing for me at first
and my process was just a bit slower but
i eventually got here
so you consider yourself an sjw i was
for about 20 years
yeah so part of the reason i voted for
trump is because i came
i came to the realization that my
ideology was not
liberalism i thought it was i thought i
was a liberal but i actually
was pushing racism and sexism in the
name of ending those things
and my old belief system has pretty much
taken over the whole party
so when i look at the candidates i think
trump is the most liberal option
he's against critical race theory he's
against collectivism he's against all
the things that
that i used to push with good intention
that i now think are
corrupting and evil so yep
yeah i think it's funny that liberals
are right wing now
look i know a lot of people and i know
because the nature of
of what i do now i'm more likely to meet
people like myself like liberals and
progressives who
have left the democratic party but i
really do my gut
tells me that there's a large number of
people that it's not just
my little um perspective that there
there
there are truly a lot of people who have
walked away i know several progressives
who just voted for trump
whoa really yes secretly no
a couple a couple of them secretly and
they're texting me and they're saying i
feel kind of gross
but kind of related
my you know what you know what felt
really good when i filled up i i live in
new jersey so it was a mail-in ballot
and i had to fill in a little that with
a pen but every little swivel of that
pen felt like
a big slap in the face f u to the
establishment yes it was enjoyable
it really was quite so i just realized
something i think
except for maybe lydia yeah everyone
here is a
democrat to deplorable yeah i think so
oh wow no no
i got a head shake no
always with people okay okay so it's
like 80 20 here
you're og because like you can't see but
but jack murphy is lovely
yeah no one can see you yeah but we all
people like ian's sitting in the room
yeah eventually we're gonna um actually
i don't know if we're able to pull the
camera out i want to
i'd like to i don't really want to
switch all night but we'll see yeah
we're gonna get one camera like in the
corner so you can see the whole room
just have people chill and hang out and
stuff chilling but yeah like i
not everybody no no no lauren chen's
here that's true yeah
brett also lifelong we're probably
pretty conservative yeah andrew just
walked in
andrew did you used to be a liberal are
you still a liberal no never
you were
how dare you early on come on guys
drinking with a trump flag does not seem
easy
no it's not but it's worth it it's worth
it
so uh i don't know actually make up for
it
we have we haven't talked about you
leaving the left because you did a long
time ago yeah
man yeah uh yeah i left during the
primaries
um in 2016. uh
i think yeah it was the beginning of
2016. it was before bernie dropped out
but you could tell that he was going to
drop out
um and i switched and
but how like why you you were so for
bernie then all said you voted for trump
well i could see that he was you know
getting ready to endorse hillary clinton
and i thought that it was rigged
and she always struck me as a war pig
she was yep correct yep she was
basically john mccain in a lipstick in a
dress
yeah and that was everything that i
opposed and so
um one day i was hanging out with noam
chomsky ironically
very cool very cool and we were talking
about free speech and why it's so
important
he's he's been horrible on trump but i
took
a very different thing away from my
conversation with him that day
so we were talking about free speech and
war and things like that
and i went back to my hotel room i went
and saw this band glass jaw play went
back to my hotel
had a few drinks in me and i was just
like you know what i'm voting for trump
and then my drunk butt started tweeting
i'm voting
and then you were locked in yeah but
were you doing that because you were mad
at hillary
um it was a little bit of both i mean
hillary clinton wanted to drone
julian assange and everybody knows that
i'm a very passionate wikileaks
supporter
um so there was that i disliked her for
for that reason i also disliked
a lot of the rhetoric that was coming
from her about like being tougher on
russia and tougher you know with syria
and things like that
um so all the things that i used to
think
were the most important to me and that
were leftist ideals like free speech and
being anti-intervention we're now being
represented by the other side
so i felt like the democratic party kind
of left my beliefs
not out yes yeah it's really funny glenn
greenwald tweeted about this recently
something about
the the democrats or the progressives
who are voting for the democratic party
who are going to get a swift lesson
in what their support is actually worth
to them once they no longer need their
votes right
and then the example he used was how the
anti-war like anti-corporatist kind of
thing
uh movement dried up as soon as obama
won yeah and that's that was me that was
like when i was you know
becoming an adult and looking at
politics and i had all these people
around me cheering me on like yeah war
is bad right and i'm like yeah and
they're like come on come with us come
vote and i'm like yeah and then i vote
in there like later
and i was like wait wait what what
i could recite obama's speeches by heart
like the one wow
about like hope and change and stuff and
i was so adamantly anti-bush because i
was the anti-war yeah i mean i had
shirts like
anti-bush shirts that would get me
visits from feds if i tweeted
pictures but i and then i was like okay
great yeah obama let's do it
and then within a year he's like
worse than bush almost and all the
people who protested at bush with me
were like yeah this guy is great i was
one of those people
yeah i quit paying attention because i i
hated w so much i was like you
yeah i joined a running club in los
angeles called run against bush and all
we did was run off our angst and our
anger with anti-bush shirts
but but i paid attention and i paid
attention to the way that cnn was
selling against the war
you know and and i i was just i was more
awake
and then as soon as obama got i voted
for him twice i was one of those people
who quit paying attention
yeah after the second time and the
second time i voted for him
as well i just i just basically was like
okay there's somebody driving who i like
and then i checked out and i know a ton
of people like me you did that
i did not i was waiting about the john
donald trump
donald trump has a popular vote lead
right now he does not indeed not that it
matters
he does but he does by uh by 0.2
of the total votes counted so far it's
meaningless i don't care they gotta
count urban centers and everything i
just think it's funny to be like wow
he's down
he's down 30 electoral votes joe biden's
at 85 to trump's 55
but trump has a small lead 0.4 percent
lead in popular vote count
isn't that interesting it is interesting
so uh so carrie what did you do
in 2016 i was one of those people who
cried
um yeah i i was wondering if i would cry
tonight for different reasons but i
actually
you know i don't really imagine being
wrong
twice yes
i came over here to win i heard this
winning i heard there
no i i just i i sort of am i think what
we're facing is a cultural problem it's
like a
philosophy problem and so i sort of
don't
know if it's going to matter that much
who wins i hope that trump wins i think
he will slow it down
but ultimately i think even if trump
wins we're going to wake up tomorrow and
we're still going to be fighting
this belief system that says that that
is taking us backwards
that says the way to cure the world's
ills is by
um putting us all in groups is with
collectivism
instead of individualism i think it's
remarkable that you could simply ask
any one of these people the average
person
do you do you agree with dr king's dream
and they'll tell you
yes and then if you ask them about the
current state of progressive activism
and leftism
they'll agree with that too which you
can't do you can't do
right they're literally the opposites of
each other yeah so
progressives like the the hardcore
activist progresses i know
straight up tell me no i don't they
don't agree with them and i'm like you
don't believe that we should and they're
like no absolutely not
they say it didn't work right yeah they
say it's time for something else
there was something really interesting
that i remember seeing i don't know if
you saw this someone wrote a letter
during the black lives matter protests
like in 2014 or whatever
saying that they believed the it was one
of the black lives matter activists
they said that ending segregation and
this is according to their letter
put black people in the same uh
competitive field with white people even
though they were a massive massive
massive disadvantage creating a
historical disparity that they could
never overcome
whereas according to this letter when
they were separated
they had black wall street and they had
their own economy in their own
system that was working so that was
black lives matter back in 2014
calling for an end to our current
status quo on you know civil rights and
segregation and stuff they wanted it
back well they've been calling for
segregation
non-stop i mean they're calling for
black student centers and colleges
they're calling for blacks only spaces
they're calling for a segregation
essentially yeah they're 100
way around it i mean that's what it is
it's frustrating to me
yep i don't want it you don't want and i
can't believe that like when i talk to
some of my good friends they're like you
don't understand it's good and i was
like it's not good for me
i was like it's remarkable
upper-class white progressives acting
like they know what any minority is
thinking or what's good for any
you know non-white person or whatever
i'm like i don't want to live in your
creepy world where
i have to like check a box and pick a
race is it my dad or my mom today i
gotta figure that one out
right screw off that's apparently the
world they want though
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8 00 pm so come back to check
us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you